Justin Bieber is once again proving he's
actually a super funny guy always during
his appearance on The Ellen Show Justin
dressed up as a Warner Brothers tour
guide to surprise unsuspecting tourists
visiting the front set so how did it go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's my favorite place to be the friend
set put your favorite character do you
have a favorite character Joey I'm Joey
guy - I'm with Joey go - can you say how
you doing all right you guys let's take
a nice photo here
[Music]
everyone stand up
check this out hasn't been washed in day
in its life look at these
[Music]
I'll tell you okay I'm gonna get the
next group in here
great great give me another pose give me
a cool pose we're excited to be here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay photo super fun also you could hear
a little bit of the the Stratford in
there yeah that accent there he's a
funny guy nice Justin Bieber when he's
on I feel like he's really on and he's a
dude I'd want to hang out with I think
it's funny that you know he shaved his
mustache but he goes back on the fake
mustache on for this Gator do you think
you would have been able to be like to
pick him out like that's your Justin
Bieber I mean just because we work in
entertainment
I feel like yes but maybe not because if
you're on vacation and you're kind of
just in that zone where you're like okay
we got to sit down take our picture go
to the next spot yeah and maybe not
right also when you see someone that
looks familiar I'm not always
immediately like you're that person
shrew right you look just like the guy
from has anyone ever told you you look
like ya Justin Bieber I don't know if
any of that's on the cutting room floor
that